tick tock is a gold mine for the latest
trends and tricks and even
that includes cleaning okay this is so
exciting i can't wait
one woman racked up 26 million views for
hypnotic video
of her cleaning and restocking the snack
drawer
of her fridge i could watch this all day
long no it's
so brilliant she's a mom from michigan
who cleans and calms with every tick
tock video she posts
and guess what rassi what she's here
know
please welcome monica brady hi monica
hi oh my gosh i'm i'm so excited to be
here with you guys
oh we feel the same way about you and
what an impressive um thing that you've
done
monica procuring millions and millions
not like
three four or five i'm talking like 25
30 million people are watching your
videos why do you
think that they're so hypnotizing and
people are so drawn to that
what's the secret so i just really feel
like with asmr and cleaning videos at
least this is the feedback that i've
gotten from like my followers
is they're really motivating for people
um
like they'll be after dinner and they'll
be you know relaxing and enjoying their
meal
and and they're like oh i just came
across this tic tac and she's
you know organizing her fridge or she's
cleaning something and it just
really motivates my followers and they
reach out to me
and they just love it and it just
motivates them and i just love
producing this kind of content for
people because of that well it motivated
me i have to say i watched your video
and then i
i attacked my refrigerator um i really
did this weekend
and i like cleaned it and turned all the
labels forward because
you gave me refrigerator envy but for
people who think that they can't do that
where do we start good question start
small would be my biggest piece of
advice
um and if anybody's new in starting
organization
i would really recommend um just like
mapping out your fridge like where do
you want the produce to go where do you
want
the drinks to go where do you want the
snacks to go um
just if everything is right up front and
just easy to grab like the produce is
washed
you know how many drinks you have you
know what drinks you have there's less
likely to be
waste in the fridge and there's less
likely to be waste of food as well at
least
that's how it is in our home that we've
you know it's everything gets eaten for
the most part
yeah if you can see it you don't waste
it it makes sense right right
now it's not just refrigerators okay
right you also went viral for a little
laundry hack
tell us about that it did so back
um beginning of covid actually
my husband and i redid our laundry space
and he put a shelf up
above the um washer and dryer and i put
all you know my laundry products up
there
and i was like this is really
disappointing because the laundry
containers are ugly
and um i found these gorgeous glass
um contain glass jars they're actually
like beverage dispensers
yeah like you would put lemonade or ice
cream
i think they're actually advertised as
an iced tea dispenser um
and they're only six dollars i'm like oh
this is awesome
such a brilliant idea so you don't have
like neon jug
on display you can have this cute little
thing and then one day i just decided
you know i'm like hey i'm gonna film
this i feel like it's something tic tac
would like and it completely blew up and
that's
where my tic tac platform started
actually
well monica what i love about what
you're doing
is that it's leading functionality and
tips
and ways to organize and make life
prettier
i am so into what you're doing i'm so
happy
that it's getting so much recognition
and i enjoy i understand
yeah i feel like i've learned so much
from you monica thanks for all these
tips
oh my gosh i'm fangirling so much
because i love
both of you and you guys like literally
watch my tic tacs i'm so
i'm so excited monica come back and
teach us more
seriously oh anytime anytime
[Music]
you